are the continuum really evil and did
they try to destroy all life in the
known universe
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so i watched all good things today now
this isn't one of those episodes if you
think about too much it's going to
scramble your brain it's all timey wimey
stuff and generally timey wimey episodes
are confusing as hell and this is no
different it there are massive plot
holes in this episode a couple of them
we're going to discuss in a minute but
basically there is this anomaly and it
is ante time
so it grows bigger the further back in
time you go and picard is being bounced
between three timelines by the q he
actually causes the anomaly by going to
the same spot in the universe in the
neutral zone in three different
timelines and shooting this inverted
tachyon beam into the same point
basically creates this anomaly now
q says this is because of the trial the
trial that started at farpoint a seven
year trial of humanity and that humanity
had been found guilty by the continuum
so
there there they were basically put up
for execution that all humanity would be
wiped from existence
let's think about that for a second they
only in the episode mention humanity
but this thing is in the neutral zone
and it is slowly filling up the universe
anti-time particles are swarming
everywhere and killing destroying all
life they prevent life on earth from
ever beginning but they would have also
prevented all life beginning on every
other planet in the alpha quadrant and
beyond given enough time this thing
would fill the known universe and it's
got 13.5 billion years don't forget
before the big bang it could prevent all
life
from ever existing so was it really
humanity that was on trial or was it
all corporal life
all of us meet sacks throughout the
universe and the continuum
just picked on humanity as
their guinea pig now q says
the time traveling bit was his idea
that's one that's a really big plot hole
here because it's the time traveling bit
that causes picard to actually trigger
the anomaly in the first place he has to
do this thing in all three timelines to
trigger the anomaly
so
it's the time traveling bit that causes
it so that's from the continuum
but q says that was his idea and then he
hints that there was a reason for it all
stuff that he's gonna find out stuff
he's going to find out in picard series
2.
i think so hopefully fingers crossed
we're all actually i'm opening picard
series 2 we figure out a lot of this
stuff with the queue and
particularly all this stuff with the
trial and we find out that there's a
reason for it all and i'm really hoping
the writers have got a really good idea
for that because it's going to have to
be a doozy
but anyway so big plot hole none of that
makes sense
but would the continuum destroy all life
in the known universe anyway remembering
in deja queue they actually punished the
queue for causing chaos in the universe
so they seem to care enough about kapoor
life
to punish the cue and turn him into a
human being and dump him on the
enterprise as punishment
for causing chaos they seem to care
about us enough to punish q for that but
then they seem callous enough to judge
us all
over a seven year period and find us
guilty and wipe us from existence
the two things don't really make sense
so i would argue perhaps this actually
didn't happen at all and it was just a
simulation
it was just something to
teach picard a lesson and we were never
really at risk anyway
if that's the case then i'm hoping again
in super card series 2 we're going to
find out what the point of that is
because they do seem to have a plan for
picard in particular i mean data in all
good things talks about cue and picard
like a master and their loyal puppy you
know and that does seem to be the
relationship they seem to want picard
and humanity and the federation is an
extension of that to grow in a certain
direction now i'm going to have another
video very soon about what i think the
queue are actually playing at here and
why they're so interested in humanity
but
that's another video
it does open up another question though
as well if this isn't a simulation this
really did happen then why did the
continuum need picard to do it why did
they need to create this scenario of
three timelines it's not to punish
picard he's about to be wiped from
existence he wouldn't know
they seem to do it because they need to
for some reason it's the only way they
could do it now if that's true then you
have to start questioning their power
because surely they could just click us
out of existence
now i would argue that actually they
couldn't because they're not as
omniscient as they say they are they say
they're all knowing or powerful but we
see q being regularly surprised
in the enterprise
you know he jumps on the enterprise and
gain and jumps up from behind the bar
store he doesn't have the ability to
detect there's somebody there never mind
already knowing that gaining was there
we see that in lots of episodes again
when q appears on voyager for the first
time he's surprised that voyager is
there he says you're not supposed to be
here for a century so he didn't even
know about that
i would argue that they're not as
powerful as they say they are and that
they couldn't do this they couldn't wipe
us out of existence without this
elaborate plan and if that is the case
then we have to start asking who are the
queue and where do they where does their
power really come from
now is it biology or is it technology
now again i'm going to do a video on
this specifically but if again if it is
all faked
this really wouldn't require any more
than a hollow deck
the technology to trick picard in this
way wouldn't be particularly outside of
the federation's capability now it
wouldn't take god like q powers
so if it is all just a simulation
that again you have to question how
powerful the cue really are remember
episodes with like moriarty on the
enterprise where they trick him into
thinking he is exploring the galaxy but
really it's just a computer program and
a little cube on someone's desk
the technology is more than available
and would be well within the
federation's ability to do if they
wanted to this episode
doesn't really make sense to me in lots
of ways if you think about it too much
it's a brilliant episode and a fantastic
finale to the series i absolutely adore
the episode but if you think about it
too much
it makes your brain all go wibbly um
massive plot holes in it and just uh
that doesn't make sense
my feeling is
that this was actually just a test for
picard that there is something coming
for picard and by extension of that the
federation
in picard series 2 that is going to
explain all of this and that this event
at the end of all good things didn't
really happen
i mean it didn't really happen anyway
because once he created once the paradox
failed and it all didn't happen from a
timey-wimey point of view anyway but i
think it didn't wonder i think it was
some sort of
q trick because to be honest
if they did do it it does make them evil
and everything that we've seen about the
continuum suggests i they're not evil
and for two even if they don't really
seem to care about us enough to wipe us
out if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification there's going to be a
couple more q videos coming up so i
would love you to drop comments and tell
me what you think about the queue
especially
are they technologically based or are
they biologically based where does that
power come from
is it something that evolved over time
or is this something they created i
really really love to know what you
think
and
please in the meantime stay safe and i
will see you next time